[Music]
natalie is with us in baltimore hi
natalie how are you
hi dave how are you better than i
deserve what's up
um well i was just tuning in to your
show not too long ago and you were
speaking about life insurance and how a
whole life has absolute junk
i never understood
how or why that is necessary or true um
okay i believed i believed that whole
life was better and i started out
seeking whole life and so i ended up
buying
a policy for each of my three kids and i
have a universal policy for my mom
and um
the policies i have for my three kids um
one is it's called a whole attempt
where you pay it for 10 years and it's
paid up
and so i did that with my oldest
daughter and she has a policy
it's only 15 or 20 000 for her yeah yeah
it's a standard standard policy the
reason you believe this is what you it's
what you've been sold okay but let's
walk let's walk through it for a minute
okay
there's two kinds of insurance as you
mentioned there's cash value insurance
and there's term insurance
all right term insurance on average runs
about 1 20th
the cost
of whole life or cash value insurance in
other words you could have bought that
same policy instead of spending a
hundred dollars you'd buy you a month or
whatever it was let's use 100 to be an
example then you'd spend five dollars a
month
so what does the extra 95 dollars that
you're going to um what does it go to
okay well it goes to build up a savings
account inside the policy called cash
value does that sound familiar to you
yes and that's why you bought it because
you thought hey it builds up a cash
value that's awesome all right and here
here's the thing
the problem is not that the problem is
that the rules or the the the guidelines
that happen to what happens to the money
in the savings account
on average it's making about one to one
and a half percent
horrible rate of return
number one
number two
if you want your money out of the policy
you either have to cancel the policy or
you have to borrow your own money now
you put the money in there
you put the money in there but when you
take it out on a loan you pay them
interest to borrow your money
well that's kind of stupid
yeah
you know you wouldn't take money out of
a savings account and borrow borrow it
from the bank you know and give them
interest to borrow your own money back
not if you're smart anyway
and then but the worth the worst part of
i mean the fees are really high the cash
value doesn't build up for many many
years but after two or three years
finally it does start building up so
it's really heavy loaded fees on the
front end and and then the worst part
though is this you got a 15 000 policy
on this kid what's the cash value in one
of those
an example
i'm sorry i don't even know what i don't
even know what the cash value on any of
them are i'll give you a guess i'll give
you a guess let's say let's say it's
five thousand dollars
if you close the policy that they'd get
five thousand dollars all right and
you've we've just established that
you've paid extra
for that five thousand dollars to be in
that policy so you have a savings
account inside that policy right
right you paid a lot more for this these
policies than you would have for the
same amount of term insurance a lot more
now so so that five thousand dollars is
in there it's your money
the problem is this
if the person that the insurance is on
dies
they don't pay the 15 000 insurance plus
your savings
they pay the fifteen thousand insurance
what happened you're saving oh
it's gone
and the only way you get
the only way you have a prepaid
insurance police are the only way you
have a 10 pay policy is that that's not
paid up it just means prepaid because
here's the deal if you're an insurance
company and you are issuing life
insurance as long as that person is
alive or as long as that policy is in
force
there is a cost to cover them because
there is a statistical probability of
their death
that after 10 years the statistical
probability of that person's death did
not go away right
so they still have a cost associated
with keeping that policy on the books
even though you've already got it paid
up
but all you did was just prepay it so
you double paid and triple paid to pay
in advance for many years to come
and that's how it gets paid up that's
the only way there's there's no such
thing as paid up insurance it just means
prepaid now they call it paid up because
that's the that's the phrase they want
to use so what would i do if i were in
your shoes
well if the people need life insurance
let's get life insurance on them make
sure the life insurance is there and
then i would close these policies
and now if they're ill and can't get
life insurance then you're stuck
and you know you're they're stuck in the
policy because their health situation
doesn't allow them to change because
they've lost their health since they got
the policy but if they have a need for
life insurance and can get life
insurance then buy the life insurance to
replace it
and then cancel this stuff and put your
investments in something else that when
you die they don't keep your money
so you just don't want to go there it's
just a really really bad place so that's
why it's just inordinately expensive it
is one of the worst financial products
on the market today the car lease the
whole life life insurance policy and the
credit card are the three things that
are keeping the middle class in the
middle
and people just they're they're just
getting messed over i mean when you
crunch the numbers on any one of the
three of those things
it makes you go ballistic about how bad
they are about how rough the consumer is
being treated in every one of those
situations so
i i stay away from it i would only
suggest and for 25 years here on the
radio i've only suggested term life
insurance and i've never suggested
anyone lease a car and i've never
suggested someone get a credit card
because they hold you back causes you to
not win
i want you to win now obviously the
people in those industries don't like me
oh well i'll have to live with that
oh darn
i really wasn't signing up to take a
poll here anyway
we're just here helping folk and if you
you know and you know who else doesn't
like me will that be the title pawning
people and the ripoff payday loan people
because i tell people they're the scum
of the earth
i mean not only you're ripping people
off but you're ripping poor people off
i mean because that's who play that's
who does title you know you notice that
payday lending is not the rich end of
town right
well they don't need it over there no
they're too dead gum smart to do it
that's why they're rich hello
so if you're just keep doing stupid poor
people stuff you'll stay stupid and poor
i mean hey i've been there i know what
it looks like i did stupid now i've done
poor i know what it looks like actually
i've never been poor i've been broke
poor is a state of mind
but i'm not gonna live like that and i'm
not gonna continue to make the same
mistakes over and over and over again
then scratch my head and wonder why i'm
still broke so you've got to make
decisions on how you're going to live
and look around and say okay this is
what wealthy people are doing let's do
wealthy people stuff
and
you know there's a few wealthy people by
whole life because they get sold to crap
too but not very many
most of us i mean i gotta tell you in
the financial advising world in the
financial coaching world the financial
counseling world i don't know anybody
that recommends cash value insurance
except people who sell it
i can't find them there's no outside
people with a that don't have a conflict
of interest looking at it like me and
going no dave you're wrong you can't add
no i can add you keep somebody's money
after they save it for 20 years at death
there's no way that's a good return on
investment it's just bad
and that's what this whole situation
comes down to
so those of you that don't like it you
don't like me oh well
i think i'll be able to live with that
this is the dave ramsey show
hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show you can do this
you know that really is a message
whether you've got 270 000 in student
loan debt or 27 000 well you've got a
fifty thousand dollar income or five
hundred thousand dollar income
[Music]